Aaron Jones joining us now Packers
running back you ever ever Scotch with
Aaron Rodgers yeah I have not I'm not
much of a scotch drinker I'm a much of a
drinker so not much of a drinker
Siderius told us yesterday Jerry Smith
said that Aaron Rodgers motto is the
team that drinks together wins together
I mean that's a great model to have I
mean that means we're getting closer yes
together means we're hanging out I don't
know you have to be drinking Mike can do
other things so you know just letting
you know I was on some close teams that
did more than you know drinking I don't
daddy cigars sometimes they smoke
together too and it's a good team we've
heard from so many Packers you know
Rogers teammates everything like that
talk about like what a fun year was what
a fun team was it why what was it about
it oh yeah I mean it was like a
brotherhood if it felt like we're in
college like you know you you you get
your group of guys and you all got your
hanging out you guys all like groups of
guys you guys go do different things
together way go be a movie bowling just
different things and a Monday night
games at people's houses these different
things we weren't doing before yeah okay
and just doing doing those things
together and it brings you closer why
why why why you guys do them this year
like what what what brought it all
together I say our leaders yeah I think
that's really where started uh they made
a sort of effort to to pick that up and
then you just start seeing other guys do
it and other guys do it and I before we
never had up us as running backs we
never had a running back dinner right
and I see those leaders start to do it
and bring us together then I'm like hey
that's how a running back dinner so
things like that I just want to hear
like when he said leaders who you
talking about give me some names the
first yeah - Darius Mercedes Lewis
Preston okay so they set the tone in the
locker room and then it kind of went one
from there yes sir and those are names
that Aaron Rodgers rattled off after the
loss to the 49ers that those are the
guys that Brian Goodykoontz the GM
brought in who who who have that
leadership mentality and then coach
Lafleur empowered guys to lead and
let them do their thing how impressed
were you by did this young guy and I
want none of us for sure what kind of a
coach he was gonna be but it looks like
he did a pretty good job getting you
guys on the same page definitely I was
very impressed I mean from day one he
came in and showed us what the offense
was gonna be in he's kind of we're all
kind of like wow this is a lot and then
as you go through the year and you're
kind of like oh this is we're doing
exactly what he said we're gonna be
doing and he brings a lot of energy
every day and it's contagious everybody
wants to be around him and his he makes
it a fun atmosphere to come to work you
you have you ready to play right but we
talked as as Darius yesterday for
whatever reason you guys weren't ready
to play in the state of California this
year like what's your assessment of that
like what and what about the trip or
what what what is it I mean I don't have
any excuses I mean you've got to be
ready to play ball I mean yeah the trips
a trip I mean teams have to make trips
every week so I don't use that as an
excuse I mean um I was ready to play
ball and I'm always ready to play ball
so did you sense that some of your
teammates weren't ready cuz Siderius
admitted he wasn't ready for that game
he wasn't ready to play and other guys
weren't ready either no I could insist
what I mean all week the the energy was
there I mean everybody felt confident
hey this is our second chance at this
we're gonna go back and handle business
it's not it's not often that you get a
second chance at things in life in we
get a second chance at this so let's
make it right so I mean I thought I felt
like everybody had bought in and
everything so I definitely didn't get
that soon not even pregame you thought
everything was really go but not even
pregame I felt like everything was ready
to go and but they they just seemed to
be flying around a little bit more right
so let's let's break that down I mean
you're one of those guys that played
both teams this year like Ellis you know
things are you know the goods and the
bads that give us the scouting report um
so I mean you you know San Francisco
they got that front for I pin their ears
back pressure they get after it I feel
like if you can kind of neutralize them
might might need a tight in or back this
connector pass protection deftly some
help steaming that up
I feel like give Patrick a little bit of
time and he'll be good and um and then
their offensive if you can if you can
stop the run
that's the the biggest thing for them if
you can stop San Francisco's running
game right I feel like and make Jimmy
Garoppolo beat you right he's capable
but make them beat you yeah yeah I feel
like that's the that's the key do you
think the Chiefs can stop the run you
had 67 yards against Kansas City which
you know that that's about as well as
anyone's ever gonna do against Aaron
Jones do you think they can replicate
that against the 49ers um I don't know
that's a great question I think they I
think it's definitely possible
um because they do fly around on that
defensive side and usually you see it on
San Francisco side as well
in the playoff something it's just amped
up I mean the lanes are a lot the
tighter they close it a hurt it close in
a hurry I mean things in the regular
season that you might take to the house
is closing so much quicker and those
guys are flying around so I mean I'm
just looking for a great game is that
the biggest difference though yeah I
mean you know we know we know the Niners
defense is the the better of the two
defenses Kansas City's no slouch but is
it just like the team speed where you
look at it as being like the difference
that separates the 49ers from Kansas
City's day
yeah I thought think as a team defense
of 49ers a little bit a little bit
faster yeah
just all-around they they just fly I'm a
fly I mean right there linebackers are
like not as fast as you but they're
close yeah yeah they're close and I mean
you see a you'll see their defense in
making a play and bought Tommy's ready
to get up and celebrate the the Safety's
down celebrating with them you're like
and that is contagious and you it gives
you hide like yeah if you're on their
sideline and you you love to see things
like this yeah um if they can neutralize
that I feel like it would be good do you
feel like you get enough credit for what
you did this you had 19 touchdowns sorry
I definitely don't but I I'm used to be
a slip on it something got the Pro Bowl
didn't go to the Pro Bowl but uh I'm
used to so just continue to work put my
head down and let that mountain on my
shoulder continue to go higher I will
say this though at one point during the
season Aaron Rodgers goes public and
says Aaron Jones should be getting MVP
consideration no that felt great I mean
coming from a future hall-of-famer MVP
himself like and he feels that I should
be in that conversation I'm not getting
talked to talked enough about and he
takes it upon himself to do that and
that's just another part of why he's
such a great leader yeah right I mean
okay like what's your anything I know
you're not the GM with the football team
but hey it's the offseason we're getting
here like any specific thing you want to
see about the Packers improve like I've
been beating the drum like I want
another like top-end receiver that's no
disrespect to guys out there but I think
it takes pressure off you Lafleur who
wants to run the ball and of course
helps Rogers and Davante Adams in that
connection I definitely agree I mean you
put somebody on the feel like that they
look at me or Tay and I can't double or
forgot it brings a different element to
the game is right I think Tyler Tyler
Irvin who came in kind of helped us with
that uh bringing the different elements
riding the speed and explosive yeah yeah
I feel like when he came in that helped
us a lot
right yeah so you said you look at the
Niners and go look at the speed they got
on that side of the ball you don't know
who the hell is gonna get a deeper
better yeah running backs all around I
mean even the fullback so yeah they have
what right yeah and they can right they
can all fly they can all move in
athletic right you know so much about
the 20 19th season came down to week 17
Sunday Night Football
pack up 49ers in Seahawks and I mean if
if Jacob Hollister gets a couple more
inches if they throw pass interference
when they should have thrown pass
interference club plays oh you guys are
the one seed the road to the Super Bowl
is going through growth in the end zone
yeah there's so you're not here right
you're not here Aaron Rodgers pictures
up on that wall and you guys getting
ready to playing a game man to see a
whole season how much rides on that one
moment how how frustrating was it for
you guys to have Seattle not win that
game I mean it wasn't frustrating I mean
we knew we were gonna if San Francisco
was gonna be in the championship loop
they're gonna be here regardless you
wanna know Lambeau Field up definitely
we wanted everything to go through
Lambeau so that was the only thing that
was a little disappointing but once we
found out
it's gonna go through San Fran we kind
of already knew that once we lost there
yeah are they in the season we some of
the guys that I already said it hey
we're not again yeah we're gonna we're
gonna come back and we're gonna beat
them it's gonna be different this time
and it didn't happen but yeah we did end
up going back yeah but you're aware of
that you're who's your pick for Sunday
honestly I honestly just want to see a
good game I have a Patrick mahomes with
my boy Jeffrey Wilson and my boy so both
different teams so I just want to see a
good come on you that crap you know no I
do want to see your game I mean I'll
play both of them in get get can we get
the Jones family to come up here come on
don't stab me first off because I want
you to say this like your parents this
is the second time I've been around you
I know they're an integral part of your
life like definitely and I know your
dad's got the military background I've
met bro before yeah San Francisco right
like was dad the kind of guy like when
you messed up he was like alright hit
the ground give me 20 like we did is
that your kind of punishment you had a
deal with that hey man my mom was in the
Army as well so you guys go to every
game season regular season every game
yes Wow right there they're always there
so make sure I look at that ticket and
make sure I know where they're sitting
that so damn yeah I didn't know you got
the whole crew we got the posse here I
mean you got everybody it's unbelievable
sister brother that uncle awesome right
yeah it's great having your own that's a
great support system it really is wait
so like when he acted up bad right all
right if he did like that great
something like what would you make him
do like what what do I mean what was the
punishment house
the punishment was you not playing all
right and then what if he acted up or
talked back to dad maybe like it what
was that every they did he didn't
well remember to get on each other I got
that twin thing going on right my wife
came up with this with this form of
discipline she called it love therapy
and she made them hold hands wherever
they went
wait well can you do it let's see I
don't want to see what it looks like
Joan's bra so mom's not looking this
what we do we owe each other's wrists
that's awesome it's great thank you for
coming up Aaron great targetted
congratulations 19 touchdowns folks he
had 19 touchdowns give these guys
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports